prize visit by Prince Harry to a court
in London this morning this was the
scene outside the courthouse when the
paparazzi suddenly realized that Prince
Harry had arrived
look at that cameras were everybody
running everybody running so this is
what's going on the hearing involved his
lawsuit against a British haploid
publisher accusing it of phone tapping
and other invasions of privacy
celebrities joining Harry in the lawsuit
includes Carlton John his husband David
furnished and actress Elizabeth Hurley
and Sadie Frost the publisher-associated
newspaper denies the allegations there's
one interesting note here it seems that
Harry probably won't be able to meet
King Charles or his brother Prince
William on this trip according to
Britain's ITV they are now in London at
the moment